A vaccine is a type of treatment for a
disease which alerts the immune system
and causes the immune system to start to act against the disease.
A drug, on the other hand, is a molecule of some type which is able to
treat the symptoms of a disease.
Our goal is to develop interventions that can help save and protect the Tasmanian devils in the wild.
We're trying to develop a vaccine which
can help to prevent
those devils in the wild from getting
the disease.
Secondly, we're interested in developing a drug which can help
cure those devils that already have signs of the disease and also
prevent them from spreading it further to other devils.
So I think a combination of these two approaches is really essential for saving the Tasmanian devils in the wild.
The really good thing about our immune system
is that it remembers particular pathogens.
So the way that we hope to make a vaccine against Devil Facial Tumour Disease
is to take these tumour cells in the lab and to make them express
very particular molecules or proteins on the surface of their cells
And then we would treat these DFTD cells in some way to make them non-harmful to the devils
so basically, stop them growing.
That means that when we put them back into the devils they won't divide and they won't cause tumours.
But what they will do is they will allow the immune system to have a look at them
and remember them for next time.
So then, the next time that the Tasmanian devils see these tumour cells they'll be able to mount an immune response against them
because the immune system will be, what we call, primed to see these DFTD cells.
At the moment we're working with the
genome sequence
and with a large drug screen here at the Sanger Institute
and we've used hundreds of candidate
drugs and screened their effectiveness in
killing or preventing proliferation of the Tasmanian Devil cancer cells
and we have found a couple of very interesting candidates
that seem to be quite effective against the devil cancer
and we're now using these drugs in Tasmania
to see if they're effective in Tasmanian devils against the cancer.